überlastete gesundheitsämter wegen der
vielen corona infektion sollen jetzt
bürgerinnen und bürger stärker in die
pflicht genommen werden so viele wie
noch nie
frankreich verzeichnet an einem tag über
40.000 neuansteckungen krankenhäuser
arbeiten am limit schlagabtausch vor der
wahl bei der letzten tv-debatte zwischen
us-präsident trump und seinem
herausforderer beiden ging es vor allem
um sachthemen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten an diesem freitag
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport als schön guten antwort von mir
die rasant steigenden corona
infektionszahlen machen den
gesundheitsämtern zu schaffen
viele sind überlastet kommen mit dem
nachverfolgen alle einzel kontakte von
infizierten nicht nach jetzt wird über
einen strategiewechsel nachgedacht
schauen wir uns die zahlen genauer an
die gesundheitsämter meldeten 11.200 42
neue fälle etwas weniger als gestern
allerdings gab es technische probleme
bei der übermittlung so dass
möglicherweise nicht alle fälle erfasst
werden konnten
es wird ja immer mehr getestet
entscheidend sei aber so das
robert-koch-institut der wachsende
anteil der positiven tests
aktuell sind gut 3,6 prozent aller
laborergebnisse positiv tendenz steigend
corona breitet sich weiter aus
david sauer auch in nürnberg steht die
korona ampel auf rot mit einer
großkontrolle versucht die polizei am
morgen masken pflicht und abstandsgebot
durchzusetzen
bei verstößen droht bußgeld alle diese
menschen die jetzt ohne maske durch die
gegend rennen die haben ja diese zweite
welle verursacht viele gesundheitsämter
schaffen es derzeit nicht mehr alle
infektionsketten nachzuverfolgen die
chefin der ärzte im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst plädiert deshalb für
ein umdenken wenn die anzahl der
kontaktperson so hoch wird ist das
natürlich eine überlegung ob man
vielleicht die kontaktperson priorisiert
und auch die meldungen die eingeht
priorisiert das heißt vorwiegend erstmal
die benachrichtigt die risikopersonen
sind oder bei denen zu erwarten ist dass
sie in einer anderen ansteckungsgefahr
mehrere anstecken können
strategiewechsel ab heute schon in
berlin dort setzt man auf mehr
eigenverantwortung
wer positiv getestet wird muss in
quarantäne auch ohne dass ein arzt das
anordnet infizierte sollen
kontaktpersonen dann selbst informieren
damit auch die sich isolieren aber das
birgt gefahren
wenn der gesundheitsämter nicht mehr in
der lage sind die kontakte vernünftig
nachzuverfolgen besteht ein restrisiko
dass eben jemand identifiziert mit dem
erreger draußen bleibt nicht in
quarantäne geht und andere anstecken
kann auf die vernunft aller ist aber
nicht unbedingt verlass das haben die
kontrollen am morgen in nürnberg gezeigt
bis zum mittag wurden dort mehr als 750
verstöße festgestellt
bisher stand eine große mehrheit der
bevölkerung hinter den corona maßnahmen
der regierung
ob das immer noch so ist oder ob der
konsens langsam zu bröckeln beginnt hat
matthias fornoff mit dem politbarometer
herausgefunden hatte matthias peter
genannt wie sieht's aus
na ja die zustimmung zu den aktuell
geltenden corona maßnahmen die ist nach
wie vor da aber sie wird etwas schwächer
die maßnahmen sind übertrieben sagen 14
prozent gerade richtig sagt eine
mehrheit von 54 prozent vor zwei wochen
waren es aber noch 64 prozent
die maßnahmen müssten noch härter
ausfallen finden 30 prozent das ist eine
steigerung um sieben punkte
schauen wir uns an wie die einzelnen
maßnahmen bewertet werden die masken
pflicht auszuweiten finden 87 prozent
richtig fast ebenso viele sind da für
private feiern zu begrenzen
kontakt beschränkungen befürworten 79
prozent nur für die sperrstunde gibt es
deutlich weniger zustimmung
bevor wir gleich zur sonntagsfrage
kommen wie sieht es denn mit der
zustimmung zu strafen und kontrollen aus
bei verstößen da zeigt sich schon der
wunsch nach entschlossenem durchgreifen
für stärkere kontrollen sind 71 prozent
und eine klare mehrheit von 62 prozent
befürwortet auch härtere strafen bei
missachtung der korona regel noch ein
kurzer blick auf die politische
landschaft unter corona vorzeichen
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die union auf 38 +1 spd 15 - 19 - 1 fdp
5 prozent linke 8 + 1 grüne 20 prozent
schwarz grün und schwarz rot hätten
damit eine mehrheit
vielen dank matthias das gesamte zdf
politbarometer gibt es heute abend im
heute-journal ab 22 uhr und auch
jederzeit online mit allen fragen und
ergebnissen zum durchklicken in unserer
zdf heute app erste präsident reinhard
rudert zurück am abend stellte er klar
dass alltags masken einen selbst und
andere vor corona schützen können
vorgestern hatte er in der zdf sendung
markus lanz noch das gegenteil gesagt
dies habe zu erheblichen irritationen
geführt das bedauere er und empfehle
ausdrücklich das tragen von masken sagt
reinhard heute seine äußerungen hatten
ihm heftige kritik auch von
ärzteverbänden eingebracht wenn aus
tarifverhandlungen wenig nach außen
dringt kann das ja eine gute nachricht
sein ein zeichen dass ernsthaft nach
einer lösung gesucht wird vielleicht
auch in potsdam wo den ganzen tag über
für die rund zwei millionen
beschäftigten des bundes und der
kommunen verhandelt wurde
es ist wohl die entscheidende phase für
die pflegekräfte haben die arbeitgeber
inzwischen ihr angebot aufgebessert jan
meyer berichtet jürgen lohr arbeitet auf
einer intensivstation der uniklinik im
saarländischen homburg der
stationsleiter hat täglich vor augen was
es bedeuten kann an cupid 19 schwer zu
erkranken arbeit im dreischichtsystem
und am wochenende sind für seine
kollegen alltag
ich finde dass anerkennung nicht
unbedingt groß drüber gekommen ist das
wird zwar für uns geklappt aber das hat
sich ja alles wieder gelegt wir arbeiten
ja genauso wie vorher auch und der beruf
finde ich als solches hat nicht die
anerkennung in der gesellschaft wie er
eigentlich haben soll dass bei den
gestern begonnenen tarifverhandlungen in
potsdam die es bislang vor allem um die
gehälter der rund 400 22.000 mitarbeiter
der kommunalen krankenhäuser und
pflegeeinrichtungen
wir haben noch mal sehr gute vorschläge
gemacht die arbeitgeberseite für die
pflegekräfte dass ich sage bewusst sehr
sehr gut diese vorschläge sehen neben
einer erhöhung von 3,5 prozent und einer
einmaligen corona sonderzahlung für alle
eine monatliche zulage von 50 euro nur
für pflegekräfte vor
doch die gewerkschaften fordern 300 euro
monatlich wirklich aus meiner sicht ja
skandalös ich benutze den begriff so ist
das angebot der arbeitgeber für die
pflege wo eine pflege zulage von 50 euro
teil ihres paketes ist bis zur stunde
ist in potsdam keine einigung erzielt
worden
jürgen [ __ ] hofft weiter dass der neue
tarifabschluss doch noch die anerkennung
für seinen beruf bringt auch in
frankreich steigen die korona zahlen
weiter schnell das
gesundheitsministerium meldet mehr als
41.000 neuinfektion an einem tag der
bislang höchste der bislang höchste
verzeichnete wert die zahl der
todesfälle steigt auf über 34.000 im
vergleich in deutschland starben bisher
neun 1978 menschen im zusammenhang mit
einer corona infektion aus paris
berichtet thomas walden frankreichs
präsident versprach den krankenhäusern
heute solidarität seine regierung
fürchtet dass sie der krise nicht
standhalten
danach riss muss unser aller
verantwortung ist und das ist wichtig
alles zu tun um das medizinische
personal zu unterstützen unsere
krankenhäuser werden auf eine harte
probe gestellt und die zahl der toten
wird weiter steigen
dortmund ii schon zu beginn der kalten
jahreszeit arbeiten viele krankenhäuser
in frankreich am limit wie hier in lyon
seid ihr kriegt es wird kritisch weil
wir alle erschöpft sind denn wir finden
kein neues personal muss wir sind wieder
da wo wir im märz waren es ist schwierig
eine herausforderung nicht leicht zu
bewältigen war es eine einfache gleiche
und sorgt in ganz frankreich für unruhe
sofort jedes mal wenn wir 1000
infektionen haben haben wir 30 patienten
im krankenhaus und davon sechs auf der
intensivstation
anders als in der ersten welle ist nun
das ganze land betroffen das erschwert
das verlegen von personal und patienten
die intensivstationen im raum paris sind
bereits zu 60 prozent mit cupid
patienten belegt operationen werden
verschoben
wir sind bereits voll alle betten sind
belegt frankreichs regierung
rechtfertigt sich der aufbau neuer
bettenkapazitäten brauche jahre sie
reagierte auf die kritische lage indem
sie die nächtliche ausgangssperre auf
immer mehr regionen ausweitet anderes
thema ein austariertes
geschlechterverhältnis bei den
wahlvorschlägen von parteien und damit
mehr gerechtigkeit
das war das ziel so genannter parität
gesetze mancher bundesländer
das prinzip ist recht einfach führt ein
mann die liste an folgt eine frau dann
wieder ein mann und so weiter nach
klagen unter anderem von fdp und npd
haben verfassungsrichter in brandenburg
diese aufteilung nun abrupt gestoppt wie
bereits im juli in thüringen warum zeigt
ihnen nicola albrecht vor dem
verfassungsgericht in potsdam hieß es am
morgen noch flagge zeigen für die
gleichberechtigung umso größer waren
enttäuschung und unverständnis bei den
frauenrechtlerinnen als das
landesverfassungsgericht sein urteil
verkündete und das paritätisch mit
nichtig erklärte die entscheidung war
einstimmig gefallen das hauptargument im
unterschied zu anderen quotenregelungen
zb unternehmen geht es hier um wahlen
also um den kern der demokratie die 50%
quoten regel verstoße gegen das
demokratieprinzip sagt das gericht weil
die parteien nicht mehr die
kandidatinnen
und kandidaten aufstellen können die sie
für richtig halten besonders zufrieden
mit dem urteil die vertreter der afg die
dagegen geklagt hatten
frauen haben die möglichkeit sich
politisch sie haben die möglichkeit sich
politisch zu betätigen und ich glaube
nicht dass der staat vorschreiben muss
das so und so viele frauen sich
politisch betätigen muss derzeit sind in
brandenburg nur ein drittel der
abgeordneten frauen auch in anderen
landesparlamenten sieht es nicht besser
aus die brandenburgische
landtagspräsidentin lied gehörte
deswegen gehofft dass das gesetz nicht
gekippt wird will sich aber für die
zukunft nicht entmutigen lassen das
frauenrecht ist auch nicht von einem tag
auf den anderen erkämpft worden und es
gab da fortschritte es gab rückschläge
und genau das erleben wir jetzt im
moment auch doch dieser rückschlag
dürfte groß sein denn eine weitere
gesetzesinitiative ist nach diesem
klaren urteil sowohl politisch als auch
juristisch erst einmal unwahrscheinlich
in die usa wo das zweite tv duell
zwischen dem us präsidenten und seinem
demokratischen herausforderer gezeigt
hat es geht auch anders war das erste
aufeinandertreffen von donald trump und
joe biden noch von beschimpfungen und
gegenseitigem unterbrechen geprägt ging
es diesmal gesittet zu strengere regeln
halfen aber auch dass der präsident
offenbar die strategie gewechselt hatte
aus washington jutta sonne wald
us-präsident trump hat diesmal wohl auf
seine berater gehört in der letzten
fernsehdebatte vor der wahl tritt tom
beherrschte auf zwischen ihm und seinem
herausforderer joe biden gibt es weniger
wütende unterbrechungen trumps strategie
diesmal er stellt den ehemaligen
vize-präsidenten als unfähigen politiker
des establishments da es gibt nur gerede
und keine taten bei diesen politikern
joe biden lässt sich nicht aus der
fassung bringen er kann punkten indem er
auf einigkeit im zerrissenen land setzt
und sich immer wieder empathisch direkt
an die amerikaner wendet sie wissen wer
ich bin sie wissen wer er ist
charakter des landes steht auf dem
stimmzettel die zentralen themen dieses
duells die korona pandemie die
wirtschaftlichen folgen rassismus und
der klimawandel
dabei stellt der präsident immer wieder
behauptungen auf die wissenschaftlich
umstritten sind
ich weiß mehr über windenergie als sie
ist extrem teuer und tötet alle vögel
die abgase die bei der herstellung
dieser gigantischen windräder entstehen
sind schlimmer als erdgas dass er sauber
ist beiden dagegen der dem pariser
klimaabkommen wieder beitreten will
bekennt sich zu einer ungewöhnlich
klaren kehrtwende beim thema energie ich
möchte schrittweise aus der ölindustrie
aussteigen ja das ist eine große aussage
weil die ölindustrie die umwelt deutlich
verschmutzt sie muss durch erneuerbare
energien ersetzt werden
die moderatorin kristin welker bekommt
für dieses geordnete duellen großes lob
die stumm schaltet taste muss sich
schließlich kaum einsetzen
eines wird hier noch mal klar
unterschiedlicher könnten trump und
beiden kaum sein in ihren visionen für
amerika also eine etwas sachlichere
debatte diesmal ines trams in washington
hat präsident tram stehen diesmal boden
gutmachen können
ja aber museen präsident trump liegt ja
in den umfragen zurück insofern war er
derjenige der unterdruck in dieses tv
duell gegangen ist doch ich denke es ist
ihm nicht gelungen mit dem auftritt am
gestrigen abend neue wähler für sich zu
erschließen für sich zu gewinnen er ist
zwar ruhiger als beim letzten mal
aufgetreten geradezu präsidial
doch er konnte nicht darlegen was seine
lösungsvorschläge sind was seine ideen
für die zukunft sind stattdessen
versuchte er immer wieder die
korruptionsvorwürfe seine
korruptionsvorwürfe gegen die familie
beiden vorzubringen
ich denke es sind vorwürfe die die
durchschnittliche familie in zeiten
einer pandemie nicht unbedingt vorrangig
interessieren
joe biden dagegen war auf die themen
konzentriert er kam empathisch rüber und
da konnte sich glaubwürdig als derjenige
präsentieren der für eine rückkehr zur
normalität steht insofern denke ich
hat es präsident trump nicht geschafft
mit dem auftritt am gestrigen abend das
ruder in seinem sinne nochmals
herumzureißen
vielen dank eines nach washington für
die kaukasusregion berg karabach wurde
eigentlich eine waffenruhe vereinbart
doch sie hält nicht neben russland hat
jetzt auch der amerikanische
außenminister pompeo einen neuen anlauf
gestartet die konfliktparteien zu einer
friedlichen lösung zu bringen er traf
sich zuerst mit seinem
aserbaidschanischen kollegen dann mit
dem armenischen wie festgefahren
allerdings die situation vor ort ist
berichtet christian zinn der keller
einer schule ist jetzt ihr
vorübergehendes zuhause in step anna
kehrt der regionalhauptstadt von berg
karabach familien suchen schutz vor dem
artilleriefeuer des aserbaidschanischen
militärs zusammen halten und hoffen in
schwierigen zeiten
ich habe fünf kinder sie hat drei all
unsere kinder sind an der front
sie kämpfen für unser recht hier zu
leben
ende september war der jahrzehntealten
konflikt wieder aufgeflammt beide seiten
geben sich gegenseitig die schuld für
die eskalation
das mehrheitlich von armenischen
christen bewohnte berg karabach gehört
völkerrechtlich zu aserbaidschan nach
dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion verlor
aserbaidschan aber die kontrolle über
das gebiet als ich die region 1991 für
unabhängig erklärte begann der krieg
international wurde die unabhängigkeit
nie anerkannt aserbaidschan wird von der
türkei unterstützt armenien sieht
russland als schutzmacht und moskau will
vermitteln
in diesem blutigen konflikt ich bin in
engem kontakt mit beiden präsident
alijew und ministerpräsident passieren
es gibt viele opfer auf beiden seiten
mehr als 2000 auf jeder seite den
jeweiligen daten nach das heißt die zahl
der opfer geht richtung 5.000 bislang
waren weniger als 1000 tote bestätigt
worden eine lösung des konflikts ist
bislang nicht in sicht alle
internationalen vermittlungsversuche
sind bislang
gescheitert zum sport und da gab es
einen traumstart für die beiden
deutschen fußball clubs in der europa
league kann man wohl sagen
hoffenheim besiegt roter stern belgrad
mit 2 zu 0 und leverkusen feiert sogar
einen rekordsieg in der europa league 6
zu 2 gegen nizza so viele tore hat bayer
an den vier bundesliga spieltage nicht
geschossen den herren von der côte
d'azur konnte es schnell schwindelig
werden so spielte leverkusen netzer aus
erst war es amiri zur 1 0-führung nach
elf minuten dann gelangen nur vier
minuten später nach technisch feinem
lupfer von baumgartlinger alaró das 20
nutzer mit einem sehenswerten
anschlusstreffer durch gary zum ärger
des leverkusener trainers 20 25 minuten
waren gute aber die letzte 20 minute war
es schlecht von unserer seite
die neu ausrichten der ansprache zur
pause half es folgten drei weitere tore
für leverkusen kurz vor schluss dass
sechs zu eins durch wird noch einmal
verkürzt nizza 6 2 nur ein kleiner
schönheitsfehler gelungener einstieg für
leverkusen in die europa league
der weltfußballer des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts feiert heute seinen 80
geburtstag edson arantes do nascimento
besser bekannt als pele 26 nationale und
internationale titel hat der brasilianer
gewonnen und wurde was keinem anderen
spieler gelang drei mal
fußball-weltmeister auch pelé der
jahrhundertfußballer ist alt geworden 80
jahre heute doch nicht nur in seinem
ebenbild bleibt er für viele für immer
jung dieser pelé den sind wir hier
geschenkt haben ist viel schöner als ich
es schon im alter von 17 jahren ging
sein stern auf fußball wm 1958 in
schweden der jüngste spieler schoss
brasilien mit sechs toren zum ersten wm
titel
die bilder des weinenden wunder stürmers
gingen um den erdball in seinem
heimatland war er fortan der könig
treffsicher wie immer auch im
sportstudio dass er insgesamt acht mal
besuchte er war für mich der beste
spieler in diesem jahrhundert und ein
großartiger mensch sein temperament hat
er sich trotz einiger operationen
erhalten pelé ist sich treu geblieben
als eine sympathische große
persönlichkeit und ein ausführliches
porträt von billy gibbons zu sehen der
zdf mediathek
bleibt noch das wetter das auch am
wochenende mit milden temperaturen und
sogar mit sonne aufwartet wo es die gibt
erfahren sie gleich von ist inter das
war es von uns danke für ihr interesse
christian sievers erwartet sie um 10 zum
heute journal
und wir sind morgen abend wieder zur
stelle punkt 19 uhr einen entspannten
start ins wochenende
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter es bleibt mild bis warm oder das
liegt hauptsächlich an den tiefs die
über dem atlantik rotieren und auf ihrer
vorderseite warme luft nach deutschland
führen ja und das wird morgen so sein
und auch übermorgen schauen wir auf die
nacht da gibt es gewitter im osten und
auch an der nordsee die lassen
allmählich nach und dann lockert es auf
und auch im süden lässt der regen
allmählich nach sonst im westen
da zeigen sich bereits die sterne
temperaturen sinken dabei auf 7 grad an
den alpen und 12 grad an der neiße
morgen tagesverlauf wird es auch im
süden allmählich trockener und dann
lassen die schauer nach im osten ist es
freundlich sonst gibt es kompakte wolken
im westen da tröpfelt es mal raus such
und auch an der nordsee ist das der fall
temperaturen erreichen höchstwerte von
19 grad am oberrhein und 13 grad in
schleswig holstein
dort ist es dann morgen am kühlsten am
sonntag kommt nach nebel die sonne
hervor im süden vor allem viel
sonnenschein im westen deutschlands
kompakte wolken mit regen bei 14 bis 21
grad und ab montag wird es etwas kühler
und vor allem im süden deutschlands ist
es dann ziemlich nass damit ein schöner
abend